l'entreprise pour experts emploie près
de dix mille personnes dans 116
boutiques au québec
super express notre force quand même une
compagnie qui étaient des impôts qui
paient des taxes qui encourage
d'économies c'est un peu déloyale que
les autres commerçants en ligne de
l'extérieur que c'est une p pauthe a
fixé la creg à la france
les breaks les produits vendus en ligne
provenant d'étrangers soit taxée comme
le sras netflix à compter du 1er janvier
la tvq s'appliquera sur les services en
ligne offerts au québec lorsqu'il ya une
certaine logique aussi à partir du
moment où le service est assez
équivalent de ce qui se fait soit au
québec ou à l'extérieur du québec
si ces taxes au québec c'est de relève
pour tout le monde léger américain
netflix a fait couler beaucoup d'encre
au cours des derniers mois en trop parce
qu'il ne percevait pas de taxes au
canada le gouvernement du québec a
choisi de faire cavalier seul en
imposant sa propre taxe on a toujours
dit qu'on allait pas augmenter les taxes
ottawa de son côté n'a pas bougé les
bémols là seulement que le québec ait
décidé d'appliquer ses toiles à aucune
province de suivi est encore pire le
fédéral a poursuivi donc c'est pour ça
que je dis qu'il ya des bémols un autre
bémol ce alors le conseil québécois du
commerce de détail concerne les produits
qui contrairement aux services ne seront
pas taxés grand nombre et cédera dit on
va donner ça à droite canada mais vous
pouvez imaginer y rendre 28 millions de
colis en provenance des états unis dans
la dernière année en 2018 puis on rentre
10 millions d'enveloppés ou colis de la
chine avec mu unique combien ça pourrait
prendre deux douaniers pour faire ce
travail là je pense que la solution pour
se parler et marc et laurent ce sont
donc des centaines de millions de
dollars qui vont continuer d'échapper au
fisc schering exactement parce que
netflix ne représentent qu'une infime
partie du commerce électronique au
québec selon le conseil québécois du
commerce de détail c'est 7 millions $ en
ce qui a trait à netflix qui nous
échappe en taxes au québec mais pour ce
qui est de tous les produits en général
dans la province c'est 350 millions de
dollars alors oui encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire
toutefois revenu québec rappelle que
vous comme consommateur lorsque vous
achetez des produits à l'étranger
vous devez payer la tvq comment pour ça
pour se rendre sur internet remplir un
formulaire de déclaration et joindre le
paiement de taxes et vous comprenez et
savez comme moi j'aime bien ce que c'est
qu'une infime proportion de la
population qu'il fait déjà
et laurence de l'année merci beaucoup
nous en voir